um i want to share some
notes some editorial suggestions that
were
prepared after the screening of a a
movie i was in
opening too choppy
why is this voice over track so terrible
he sounds drugged were they all on drugs
deckard at the piano is interminable
flashback dialogue confusing is the
listening to a tape why do we need the
third
cut to the eggs the synagogue
music is awful on the street
we've got to use van gaalis up to zora's
death
the movie is deadly dull
this movie gets worse every screening
that movie was called blade runner
and these notes can help us understand
why the editing process
can often get a little complicated
the possibilities may seem endless
but the editor will work tirelessly
often
in isolation to make thousands of
choices
placing the right piece of the right
length
in the right order to arrive at the best
version of what the movie wants to be
it's an extremely difficult process
not for the impatient not for the faint
of heart
you've got to really love making movies
tonight's nominees for best film editing
are the father
yogush
nomad land chloe jowl
promising young woman federic torival
sound of metal michael
e.g nielsen
in the trial of the chicago seven alan
boongarten
and the oscar goes to
sound of metal
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you academy and
fellow nominees your inspiration for me
um i'm from denmark
and i would like to greet denmark
because
they are extremely bold at
funding the danish film school so we
students can develop our craft and
language for four years
that's amazing this is what you get so
just continue doing it
i would like to thank eve and angus
and my amazing assistant alex
and my whole family at rock paper
scissors you guys
raise the bar i would like to thank my
agents
hillary and rebecca
i would like to thank emerson
and caviar and everyone from cast and
crew
for sharing your enormous talents
the deaf community for inviting me in
front very inspiring and rewarding world
i would like to thanks all my friends my
families
my parents i have to remember my parents
my sisters my wife shoot it and my kids
mingus and ella they always allow me to
spend time with
my big love affair editing so thank you
for that
but one above all various matter
thank you for your incredible vision
thank you for inviting me on this
life-changing
i would say journey and
it's been like following a rainbow for
me and today
i feel like we found the gold thank you
you